what is up guys this is statistically
challenged here and today I've got
another video for you guys I just wanted
to thank you guys for 1000 subscribers
like last week we just had 500 an hour
already at 1000 pretty sweet I just
wanted to thank all of you guys who
subscribed I really appreciate it let's
get on with the video
Dave you're gonna have an hour to see
how much we can make only buying stuff
from the tree gnome stronghold shop now
there are a lot of ways to get there but
what I'm going to using is a skills
necklace teleport to the fishing guild
so yeah as you guys can see you will be
teleported right in here all you need to
do is get right here so we're just going
to be running east over this bridge and
then come to the tree gnome stronghold
gate so ya guys once you're here you're
just gonna walk through this gate and
then run directly north
[Music]
once you are here at the base of the
tree you just want to go through the
door and climb up the ladder one time
and you should be q guys so for this
challenge as I said we are going to be
starting with 10000 GP the reason I
picked that is because it's an amount of
money anyone can acquire for free just
doing the stronghold security as you
guys can see there are a lot of shops on
this floor we have all these NPCs who
sell different items and what we are
going to be doing and see how much we
can make starting from 10000 GP as you
can see the banks are just right here so
we're just gonna start at the bank and
start the timer let's do this guy's so
the first shop probably gonna hit up is
this shop right here I have no idea what
to expect right now the gnome waiter
this stuff's actually quite expensive I
thought this was gonna be like 2 coins
so this shop is probably not the one we
want it we want to use they both saw the
exact same things we're gonna go over
here to Hugh doh okay this is more like
it we have a huge selection of stuff
uribe cocktail shaker crunchy tray two
pineapples here how much do these go for
I'm expecting these to not go for much
at all bucket of milk I wonder how much
that is they ever gonna check a few of
these items out pineapples 173 GP that's
huge Dom limes only 91 the orange is
only 68 yeah these these kind of suck we
are going to head over to the other side
like I said there are shops on the other
side I could just buy one of each but
you need this for a quest so I'm
assuming it'd be like a couple hundred
GP pre-made blueberry special is 282 GP
well that's actually pretty good
alright just for you know just for
experimental purposes I honestly have no
idea what these are used for but I'm
going to just buy one of each you know
you never know what one of these you're
gonna cost a lot like I thought these
are pretty much worthless another shop
here heckle punch
now Michael punch does have a lot
pineapples I think I'm gonna bite those
out I'm also gonna get each type of
liqueur from this guy store we're gonna
see how much those go for
[Music]
the crates at the last shop here is fine
fashions and it actually sells a bunch
of clothing all right so I've
experimented with some items and I've
just put them all into a loot tab now I
think I have a pretty good idea of what
I'm going to do see I'll get back to you
guys what's up at the shops first we're
gonna always buy these ten pre-made
blueberries specially required for a
quest I believe so they are gonna be
good then we're gonna come over here we
can get the ten bought cuz probably get
the pineapple as well and I think that's
really it I don't see much I don't see
too much we could have here so
everything go right back to the bank
keep in mind there we only spent a few
GP and that's like a 5 point 4 K profit
right there so again this is really good
again we'll just deposit them into the
new tab and go right back alright guys
so I came back to heckle punch and I
just remembered of something that's
absolutely crazy you can actually make
your own glitterberries specials if we
look at the GE price right now some of
these I've been selling for 12,000 GP
this is still within the rules because
I'm only using the shops so what we're
gonna do is just make a few blueberry
specials and see how it goes this
actually might make us a lot of money
because I know it only costs a few GP to
make one so yeah if you buy the cocktail
shaker and you mix it if you can
actually make all of these different can
make all these different cocktails and
as you can see the blueberry special it
only requires a few items so let's go
ahead and make one real quick we seem to
be needing two lemons here or two limes
I forgot which one of this we're just
gonna buy one of each alright so we just
made one blueberry special keep in mind
this isn't the pre-made one so it's
gonna be worth more we only use like a
couple GP here how much is that worth
see it's saying the repoint 6k but I'm
pretty sure in the GE it's worth more
okay we're just gonna we're gonna try to
make like an inventory of these and sue
it out
[Music]
all right that didn't take long at all
and we already have two of these so you
like this so we're gonna take a full
inventory and see if it's worth it all
right guys so right now we've made
around seven blueberry specials it only
took us a couple minutes but there are
other things in here like the trunk
dragon chocolate Saturday fruit blast
I'm gonna make a few of these just to
find out or see how much they're worth
because you know some of these might be
worth alot as well so we're gonna start
off with the wizard blizzard some of
these have some weird freaking
ingredients so your entire best year
[Music]
this is 24 GPE but I don't think it's
gonna be 20 40 people and bringing to
the GE it's gotta be more anyways what's
the next one short green guy this one
looks pretty easy to make alright so we
just made that one how much is that
worth 23 GP again I don't think that
it's only gonna be worth 23 GP as who
the hell ever makes this [__] like let's
be honest next we have the fruit blast I
don't actually know where you'd use this
in the game look like but we'll see this
one's actually really easy to make so it
would be kind of convenient if this one
was worth something alright so as you
guys can see this one's actually worth
something umm right now this one
actually is worth something it's really
nice because these don't take long at
all to make I do still think though that
the fruit or sorry the blueberry
specials are the best so we're gonna
just continue making as much as we can
as you can see the inventory space is
getting quite limited but look how much
we've used we've only used 2 K so far so
we've been buying these ingredients so
much that we have to actually will top
here so we're gonna do a real quick all
right there we go full stock let's get
back to making some blueberry specials
[Music]
so we're gonna do now is just go back
and Bank because our inventory space is
quite limited right now and it's getting
really annoying just trying to figure
everything out in my inventory so let's
just Bank I'm just gonna take the
ingredients for the blueberry special
out right now cuz I don't want to have a
lemon just sitting around a mandatory
doing nothing really right so I'm gonna
head over to the other side now cuz I'm
getting kinda bored I'm just gonna buy
the pre-made fruit blasts and a premade
blueberry specials I forgot to check the
fruit bless oh they're only 20 GP well
what can you do
yeah we are it's a 23 minute mark and I
think it's looking pretty good so far
right we just pick up three of the
pre-made chocolate bombs and three of
the pre-made TTL the shop is really
interesting because it does sell a lot
of stuff but I don't know if any of it
is really worth just buying if anything
only the pineapples would really be
worth buying here although the dwell
berries do seem pretty tempting so I'm
just gonna buy a couple of those for now
I think that's on me to buy from this
shop so yeah guys I'm heading back to
Peggy lunch
honestly if I want to see what the most
I can make with my money honestly the
most with the best thing you can do with
your money is honestly just buy the
ingredients for the blueberry specials
and just make them continuously but I
want to actually use all the money I
have in my inventory so what we're gonna
do is just we're gonna Bank all this
stuff that I just bought
make a few blueberry specials and then
hit up the clothing store and ply just
do a few more trips of those I'm gonna
be honest making these is just as
tedious as it looks
[__] I accidentally just drank one again
we have to hop world's because the lemon
is out of stock because every single
time you make one of these you have to
use three of them here we just made
another nine blueberry special as you
guys can see making an item worth like
5k from 20 GP everytime and it's taking
quite a while so I think I'm just gonna
experiment with these pink robe and
again we're done another inventory let's
just bank all of this stuff you know
this challenge was how much can I make
just spending this cash with the time
limit of an hour I think I'm just gonna
start buying these robes out yeah guys
we only have 57 GP because we bought all
these robes probably just a few
pineapples we have to spend 37 GP
somewhere so we're just gonna wear these
robes and just buy one pre-made
blueberry special we will just buy one
lime one vodka that's it all of the
money 10,000 GP has now been used on the
shops here we can stop the timer that
took 35 minutes to complete the
challenge so this is what 10,000 GP can
buy you we are going to go back to the
GE now and sell all of this using these
skills necklace again we just go to the
cooking guild and we are right here
okay guys I'm just gonna pull this all
out
[Music]
the vodka I'm just gonna put this in for
2gp because I don't think secure so much
oh she this whole for 316 each and we
got six case oh yeah so we pretty much
made 10k back already
let's sell all this stuff now and see
how much we can make
[Music]
again these go for a 180 GP and their
last but not least guys we have the
blueberry specials I'm just gonna sell
one because I'm kind of curious what I
would go for 10,000 GP wait so you're
saying if I sold all these right now I
would get oh no only a few for buying
guys unfortunately I am going to have to
dump these 60k alright they they went
for 3k h please you can see if you guys
want to flip blueberry specials there's
a quite big there's quite a big margin
on them but at the end we turns 10,000
GP into 122 K just by using these shops
located in the gnome stronghold of
course if you went the route I did with
the blueberry specials you would need 35
cooking earth sorry 37 cooking I know
you guys did enjoy the last to be Rock
Shop challenge so I try to make a video
similar to that one there are a lot of
shops around the game so I do encourage
you to go experiment and see what you
can actually buy because with these
challenges you spend minimal GP and you
can see if we pretty much multiplied our
money by 12 just using shops in the game
so if you guys enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up comment on
what you want to see next you know I do
take some suggestions from the comments
and times entering them into videos
preferably make it a 1-hour challenge
thank you guys again for 1000
subscribers if you want to see more
concept for me be sure to subscribe and
watch my other videos if you enjoy what
you saw today make sure you guys stay
tuned because today or either tomorrow
I'm going to be releasing a beastly
1-hour challenge video that honestly
could be better money making than sorrow
so stay tuned for that guys until then
have a good day